[Music]
are there particular
modalities
frameworks tools that you have found to
be particularly helpful in
working with individuals who have trauma
in their background
sure no i think it's a it's a great
question and
i mean there are many arrows in the
quiver
right and cbt is is an hour when the
quiver dbt is an arrow in the quiver
medicines can be an arrow in the quiver
but where it all has to start
is is a search for truth right because
trauma changes our
our emotions about things right our
feelings and emotions about things it
then changes what how we think right and
what our memories mean so we need to
look at what is the person's narrative
about trauma if they're identifying that
there's trauma and if not what is the
narrative about self
right because in unless we we understand
that then it's like trying to solve a
problem so you're trying to solve a math
problem but you don't know what the
equation is right like we're not going
to pick the right tool we're not going
to get to the right place so because
there's so much reflexive shame and then
a cascade that comes after that right
and a lot of times that involves like a
decrease in role performance right where
now the person doesn't they're not
performing their role say as a parent or
as an employee or as a friend as well
right then the person begins to think of
themselves in a different way and the
first thing to get at is what is the
person's narrative so someone who may
present and say oh i've you know i was
really got physically hurt in my last
relationship
but you know
i mean this is always what happens or
it's never you know never
goes any differently right i mean you
have to you know instead of looking okay
let's look at the trauma from this thing
that happened to you in your last
relationship you have to look at why is
the person approaching
the whole question of relationships from
a place that says things won't be okay
for me right what are the lessons that
that person has learned that are not
actually true
right and you have to go back to why
when did the person start thinking of
that i mean people don't i mean i'm
saying it for a fact right but people
don't pop out of the womb thinking no
one's gonna treat me well i don't
deserve to be treated well right i
always get hurt in relationships like
where long did that conception come into
play and how much does that person also
maybe feel they don't deserve anything
better where did that come from right
and if we go back and we look at the the
formation of a narrative that then
furthers and perpetuates trauma then we
can get at
changing it right but then you have to
get out what are the the pain that the
person felt right you know the the
emotions involved you have to go to a
place that's emotional but if you go to
that place
the actual events the emotions the
change in conception of self or
conception of the world then you can
come through and say okay what tools
does it make sense for us to apply right
because there are the arrows in the
quiver that you noted and a lot more
the question is knowing hey when does
one make sense versus another and i try
and i write a lot about strategies
antidotes in the book right and and i i
think they're you know in a sense
they're good ideas but i think they're
good ideas but they're good ideas only
if they're applied in the right
situation to the right person so it goes
back again to understanding the person
what happened to them and how what is
their narrative of themselves and what
the world can or can't be for them
you